ولدينا تقرير جديد الليلة من
مركز الملفات، وهو عبارة عن
مجموعة تحقيق تتعقب النشاط الإجرامي
المرتبط بالكرملين، يقول إنه
منذ بداية الغزو،
توقف فلاديمير بوتين في أغلب الأحيان عن
استخدام طائرته الخاصة، كما ترون
هناك.  اعتاد أن يفعل ذلك، كما تعلم أن
رئيس الدولة بأكمله نزل على
الدرج، لكن الآن
هذه هي وسيلة النقل المفضلة لديه
وفقًا لملف
المجموعة التي يديرها ميخائيل كوداكوفسكي،
وهو زعيم معارض، يسافر بوتين في
الغالب في هذا القطار المدرع المجهز
بمركبة خاصة.  نظام الاتصالات
لماذا القطار في وقت سابق تحدثت مع
إيليا روز ديسفينسكي، مراسل
مركز الملفات، وأخبرني أن
الرئيس الروسي يخشى أن
السبب النفسي لاستخدام هذا
القطار هو أنه خائف، إنه خائف من أن
يعلق في فخ ذلك القطار.
يمكن أن تكون الطائرة محاصرة بحيث يمكن
إغلاق خطته من قبل القوات الجوية لحلف شمال الأطلسي أو أو من قبل
القوات الجوية الأوكرانية أو لماذا يمكن أن يحدث
صاروخ ما أو نوع من الصواريخ التي ضربت
جسر القرم أو أي شيء من هذا القبيل،
لذا فهو خائف ويعتقد
أن  إنها طريقة أكثر أمانًا للسفر
حيث لن يعرف أحد إلى أين يتجه
ولن يفهم أحد أنه داخل
السلسلة
ولن يعرف أحد لأن روجاسفينسكي
يقول إنه يبدو كقطار ركاب عادي
باللون الرمادي مع شريط أحمر من
صنع قطار الركاب الروسي  ليس هناك
خطأ على الرغم من أن هذا القطار بالذات
ليس مثل الآخرين،
فهناك ثلاث قاطرات
يدربها بوتين لديه ثلاث منها لأنها
ثقيلة حقًا أه وهي مدرعة ولذلك فهي
ثقيلة وتحتاج إلى المزيد من القاطرات هذا
القطار به نوع من
المعدات الخاصة للقطارات الخاصة  الاتصالات التي
يريد توصيلها بشكل آمن يحتاج إلى
بعض الخطوط الخاصة للتواصل
مع رئيس وزرائه والمسؤولين الآخرين
والتأكد من عدم
الاستماع إليه من قبل بعض المخابرات الأجنبية
ويمكنه رؤية جزء من هذا أه جزء من
هذه المعدات على سطح  اه من
السيارات
يمكنك رؤية جزء منها من السطح
وهي ثقيلة وهي مدرعة لذلك يستغرق
نقلها ثلاث قاطرات وليس
جنرال واحد فقط يندفع في هذا
السياق لأنه كما يذكر ستيف اه
كودوركوفسكي هي مجموعته
مجموعة الملف هي التي فعلت  كل هذا أه هذا
البحث هو بحث مضني على
القطار قطار بوتين لذلك
أوضح المراسل هناك إيليا سبب استخدام بوتين
لهذا القطار هنا، إنه مرة أخرى إنه
خائف إنه خائف من أنه يمكن أن
يُحاصر أن طائرته يمكن أن تُحاصر
فيه أن خطته يمكن أن  أن يتم إغلاقه من قبل
القوات الجوية لحلف شمال الأطلسي أو أو من قبل القوات الجوية
لأوكرانيا أو لماذا يمكن أن يحدث صاروخ ما أو نوع
من الصواريخ التي ضربت جسر القرم أو
أي شيء من هذا القبيل، لذا فهو
خائف ويعتقد أنها
طريقة أكثر أمانًا للسفر.  لن
يعرف أحد إلى أين يتجه، لن
يفهم أحد أنه داخل النهر
ولن يحاول أحد حتى أن يفعل شيئًا
بهذا القطار.
على مستوى معين، إنه
لأمر مذهل أن نقول إن القطار الصحيح يسير بسرعة
50 إلى 70 ميلاً في الساعة.
للالتزام بالمسارات التي يمكن للجميع رؤيتها عندما
يتحرك القطار، إنه
أمر مذهل للغاية أن نقول إن هذا كما تعلمون أن
بوتين يشعر بقلق شديد بشأن
احتمال إسقاط طائرته لدرجة
أنه لجأ إلى التدريب، وهو شيء تم القيام به
في عصر ستالين  أو من أمثال
كيم جونغ أون،
نعم آرون، ما أود قوله هو أن الرئيس
زيلينسكي بالمقارنة
يتجول في ساحة المعركة بشكل جيد، لقد
كان في جميع الخطوط الأمامية
وظهر أمام الكاميرا مع الجنود على
الخطوط الأمامية في الخنادق التي كان فيها
هناك عدة مرات في كل
المواقف، إذا كان لدى بوتين هذا الجيش العظيم
الذي تحدث عنه السيد لوكاشينكو للتو، فهل
هو حقًا قلق من أنه
سيضطر إلى الانتقال من موسكو إلى سان بطرسبرغ
إلى مينسك في قطار مدرع الذي
أود أن أقترحه وربما يستطيع ستيف ذلك
تحدث أكثر عن هذا الأمر الذي يمكن
التقاطه بسهولة عن طريق إشارات الاتصالات
والمراقبة الجوية، فهو خائف كما
قال أحد المراسلين من الملف أنه
سيُقتل وهذا ما
يفعله المستبدون عندما يكونون في
أوقات سيئة حقًا ولا يفعلون ذلك.  لا يثقون بشعوبهم
ولا يثقون بجيوشهم أعني ستيف
ماذا يقول هذا عن استخدام بوتين لهذا
القطار الذي تعرفه كما قلنا أنك
تعرف مكانه ومتى يتجه إلى
هناك ماذا يقول ذلك عن ذهنه،
نعم إذا كان هذا  التقارير دقيقة
وبالطبع علينا أن نتذكر أنها
تأتي من هوليوكوفسكي الذي لديه القدرة على
اختيار بوتين لذا فمن المفيد أن نظهر
له الخوف ولكن إذا كان هذا صحيحًا وبالطبع
فعل ستالين هذا فمن الممكن أن يكون
صحيحًا وبالطبع  الكوريون الشماليون يفعلون
ذلك، لذا فإن هذا ليس أمرًا غير
مسبوق،
ولكن كما تعلمون أن هناك إيجابيات
وسلبيات، كما تعلمون، من السهل اكتشاف الطائرات
بمعنى ما، هناك
توقيع إلكتروني تقلع به وتهبط في
المطارات، وهناك مراقبو ذيل، وهناك
كل الأنواع  من الطرق التي يمكنك من خلالها العثور على
الطائرات، أه، كما تعلم، قد تكون هناك
ظروف معينة
يصعب فيها رصد القطارات قليلًا، أعني أن
هناك اتصالات أقل ولا يمكنك رؤيتها
وهي تطير في الهواء إذا كنت
مراقبًا للذيل، ولكن إذا كانوا'  لقد حصلت على
حزمة الاتصالات الخاصة التي
يتحدثون عنها، ثم يقومون
بإصدار شيء ملحوظ، يبدو الأمر
كما لو أن هذا
قطار مثير للاهتمام وبالمناسبة يتم سحبه بواسطة
الكثير من القاطرات ويبدو أنه
مختلف عن القطارات الأخرى، لذا فأنت  أعلم أن
هناك إيجابيات وسلبيات، لكنني
لن أقول إن
السفر بالقطار آمن تمامًا، لكنه
يعكس ما إذا كان صحيحًا ما تعرفه عن
عقلية بوتين، كما تعلم، وهو أنه
ملفق بالفعل،
وأود أن أقول شيئًا آخر إذا استطعت
يجب أن يظل قطار آرون على مسار
لا يمكن أن ينحرف عن هذا المسار، لذا
ليس هناك قدرة كبيرة على
تجنب استهدافه